turning to the pandemic and new concerns
about a spike in cases just ahead of the
christmas holiday
it's ten days away from today these are
the scenes in new york city where covet
testing sites are seeing long lines and
wait times like this the cdc says that
omicron strain has now been found in at
least 36 states the seven day average of
daily cases nationwide is now
approaching
120 000 and that's the highest in about
three months the cdc expects the weekly
number to surge 55 in the coming days to
1.3 million new cases during christmas
week meg oliver is at a testing site
right here in new york city may good
morning to you what can you tell us
gal good morning this clinic just opened
and as you can see people are already
lined up down the block looking to get
tested cases here are up about 109
percent in the last two weeks one expert
told us that number could jump to a
million new cases a day nationwide come
january
we expect to see the proportion of
omicron cases here in the united states
continue to grow in the coming weeks the
cdc is warning that early data shows
omicron cases in the u.s are doubling
about every two days but dr anthony
fauci says there is good news
at this point there is no need for a
variant specific booster if you are
unvaccinated get vaccinated and
particularly in the arena of omicron if
you are fully vaccinated get your
booster shot according to the cdc those
who are unvaccinated are eight times
more likely to be hospitalized and 14
times more likely to die from covet
compared to the fully vaccinated around
65 percent of eligible americans have
two doses of the vaccine but only around
30 percent of people over 18 have their
booster the booster do not think of it
as a bonus it is a necessity as cova
cases tick up states businesses and
schools are taking action
after hundreds of students recently
tested positive for covet at both
cornell and princeton the universities
moved final exams online princeton and
nyu are now among several schools
requiring students to get their booster
before returning to campus for the
spring semester in philadelphia where
cases have doubled in recent weeks the
health commissioner is urging residents
to cancel their holiday parties and
avoid gathering indoors
but if you do plan to attend a holiday
gathering indoors infectious disease
specialist dr celine gander says open
windows and doors to help with
ventilation and try to get a hepa air
filter if possible and make use of rapid
tests what is your biggest concern when
it comes to omicron right now how
infectious it is so even if it turns out
that omicron causes milder disease if
more people are infected with a milder
disease you could end up with just as
many deaths
a new study by yale university and the
health care research group the
commonwealth fund found that the u.s
vaccination program likely saved more
than a million deaths now we do know
that
the cdc yesterday called vaccines a true
powerhouse
we know they work meg thank you very
much